I'm sorry okay this is pretty crazy i'm
maria idle president CEO of the nike
foundation women right over there I'm
always being interviewed by sheryl
sandberg the CEO of facebook totally
crazy the day before i came to Davos I
was in bahadar Ethiopia at a child
marriage project and I was meeting with
girls and it was incredible there was
the world ever wanted to tell me her
story and she had been married when she
was nine years old and she read me a
poem that she wrote and her poem was
about how angry she gets when she sees
other girls who get to go to school and
asked her why she wrote it and she said
she wrote it because it made her feel
better because she has that inside and
it made me think when I got here sitting
in sessions about corruption political
stability and health and economic
opportunity it may be pickin the points
of every young person on this planet and
if we could hear every single one of
those voices like the girl who wrote
that home how different things would be
and it may be think that is our
obligation those of us who get to come
here and be here to go faster and do
better for young people in the world
because it is not they are not the
future they're the now and it's about
you and we got to do more faster better
so that's what it motivates me to be
here and to try to do something to help
she's really good at this mr. all your